[Música]
quando o meu filho mais velho nasceu
hoje está com quase 12 anos vai fazer
sábado aniversário eu decidi que eu
queria gastar o meu tempo na cozinha e
não cuidando de criança doente que eu
amo meus filhos mas criança doente mesmo
quando nós é muito chato
então eu fui estudar eu fui saber o que
eu fazia para eles comerem bem o que eu
fazia por eles terem muita saúde que
acho que a alimentação pilar principal
da nossa saúde
e aí eu descobri a primeira coisa mais
importante não consumam industrializados
e na verdade todas as dicas que eu que
eu pesquisei e divulgo pros meus filhos
valem que eu sempre digo para crianças
de 0 a 100 anos então primeira coisa
evitar o máximo industrializado como é
que a gente evita industrializado quando
a gente trabalha o dia inteiro não tem
tempo pra nada chega em casa cansado a
gente se programa e como é que a gente
se programa gente escolhe um dia da
semana onde do mês aquele dia que tá
frio chovendo que você não vai ter que
ter muito que fazer na rua
nesse dia você faz comida a mais e
congela em porções aí vem mais uma dica
ao freezer é o melhor amigo da comida de
verdade
então se você tiver espaço em vista no
freezer
vale muito a pena outra coisa que eu
sempre fiz com os meus filhos e dá muito
certo eu sempre levei eles as compras
comigo especialmente na feira porque no
supermercado tem muita tentação então
nasceram ia falando o nome de cada
verdura legumes fruta para eles irem se
familiarizando deixava cheirar deixava
tocar é e só acho que ajuda muito a
criança está familiarizada com aquilo
não há um ser estranho que caiu de
paraquedas
no prato dela então ele vai na compra eu
sempre cozinhei em casa e de novo quem
não tem tempo escolhe um dia e se dedica
a isso aquele dia que você ia ficar
cuida do teu filho doente vai com ele
para a cozinha é muito mais divertido do
que com ele pra cama cuidado ele
resmungando que está doente e mamãe dói
aqui doyle não é legal quando for para o
supermercado é ler o rótulo das coisas
aquele salgadinho que ele viu amiguinho
comer e e pediu pra comprar também aqui
há aquela bolachinha aquela coisa leia
com ele vai ser instrutivo pra você e
vai ser instrutivo para o teu filho como
os meus como eu tive essa consciência
desde o início a gente começou desde o
início a com comidas naturais não usando
industrializado e eu inclusive fiz
questão de dificultar a vida deles
eu comecei com o que era mais difícil de
gostar é que vocês acham que é mais
difícil mais fácil uma criança ou
qualquer adulto gostar uma salada de
rúcula uma barra de chocolate
eu não sei vocês a maioria vai preferir
a barra de chocolate então com eles eu
comecei com a cúpula com aquele que é
amargo que é meio azedinho é mais
difícil eu estou formando o paladar da
criança quando você começa do zero da
barriga até é muito mais fácil o que não
torna impossível você pegar uma criança
maior e reeducar o paladar dela é um
pouco mais difícil mas não é impossível
a principal dica nesse caso é de novo
vá para a cozinha mas neste caso leva
seu filho junto tá ele vai fazer cara
feia para muitas coisas
ele vai torcer o nariz ele vai recusar
muitas coisas mas eu acho que com o
tempo ele vai se familiarizando quanto
mais velho a gente fica mais resistente
a mudanças a gente fica a gente o ser
humano é um ser que gosta do conforto
então sair da zona de conforto é muito
complicado mas não é impossível
outra coisa superior
te falei do freezer bom mas hoje em dia
os apartamentos estão cada vez menores a
gente não tem espaço para ter um freezer
daquele ótimo freezer é caro é grande ea
gente não tem espaço então o que fazer
a rede de apoio gente se junta aí com
mais duas três amigas ou familiares que
estejam na mesma fase de vida que vocês
então tá com o filho mais ou menos a
mesma idade e faz um rodízio então essa
semana você faz uma quantidade grande
distribui para as amigas
então a menos coisa no freezer por vez
na outra semana a outra amiga faz a
outra faz vocês combina o cardápio entre
vocês
uma dica para quem está aqui em são
paulo nós estamos marca um piquenique no
parque da água branca sábado lá tem uma
feira de orgânicos todo sábado de manhã
para as crianças é uma enorme diversão
porque a feira em si é muito instrutiva
e o parque é muito gostoso tem animais
você vê o que leva as crianças de volta
para a fazenda sem sair da cidade grande
é muito interessante
não tenha medo de temperar a comida do
seu filho é porque que o industrializado
é tão gostoso
ele é feito pra gente gostar dele né em
os caras estudam anos a fio cada produto
que eles vão lançar porque esse produto
se extremamente atraente na aparência e
no paladar e porque a comida que a gente
faz em casa não pode ser igual porque a
comida de casa tem que ser sem graça
então assim brinca de temperar usa a
erva fresca erva seca usa aquele
sozinhos têm curtem tenho páprica tem
tantos temperos começa a pesquisar é um
mundo fascinante eu enfim sempre cresci
comendo comida de casa meus pais faziam
muito eles não tinham conhecimento que a
gente tem hoje eu fui atrás eu fui
estudar né
mas eu sempre tive acesso e ele
trabalhava o dia inteiro todos os dias
da semana isso não era desculpa para não
fazer a comida é óbvio que nós ficamos
muito cansadas cada o qual na sua
profissão inclusive a profissão ser mãe
é muito exaustivo
é uma delícia mas é extremamente
cansativo mas não deve ser uma desculpa
porque de novo
cuidar de filho doente dá muito mais
trabalho é muito mais cansativo do que
fazer comida
se a gente erra de vez em quando de vez
em quando não a gente erra muito
especialmente no nosso alimentação é
porque tem tantos estudos falando coisas
diametralmente opostas tem tanta gente
que faz um jeito dá certo o outro faz
outro jeito dá certo o jeito errado dá
certo
ninguém morre porque como uma besteira
isso é uma coisa muito importante de que
a gente sabe a gente entender criança
não quebra a criança não quebra criança
não derrete a gente vai errar muitas
vezes a maioria delas sem querer
às vezes a gente vai sim errado de
propósito porque sentar numa tarde de
sol num barzinho numa lanchonete e comer
uma porção zona de batata frita com milk
shake é uma delícia né e é uma coisa que
eu sempre falo que saúde para crianças
de 0 a 100 anos saúde é um conjunto de
três coisas é o bem estar do corpo da
mente e do espírito nem tudo que faz bem
para o corpo vai fazer bem para a mente
o espírito e vice-versa o que a gente
tem é que ter o equilíbrio nosso corpo
tem que estar bem tratado mas a cabeça e
o espírito também então a gente tem que
aprender a equilibrar a cada um tem sua
forma a criança não tem fórmula mágica
tá uma vai gostar mais do seu trabalho
do salgado uma vai comer de tudo o meu
filho mais velho por exemplo nunca me
deu trabalho pra comer qualquer coisa
que eu colocasse na frente dele comia o
meu mais novo com tudo o que eu fazia em
casa com o maior cuidado me dedicava de
uma hora para outra ele só queria como
farofa e urt gente juro era pavoroso ele
não comer mais nada para o fim o guti e
lá fui eu agüentei um ano nessa história
tentando misturar uma coisinha ali uma
coisinha aqui pra variar um pouco sempre
colocando tudo que eu
achava que ele tinha que comer no prato
dele mas sabendo que ele só ia na farofa
no iogurte e foi sobreviveu
acertamos a hoje ele cobre de tudo e faz
é muito curioso o dia ele resolveu um
dia pro outro e é comer de tudo e outro
exemplo muito bacana que eu tenho de uma
criança que ela não era particularmente
ruim para comer mas ela não comia
verdura de jeito nenhum
é eu fui dar uma aula para pais e filhos
mães e filhos em fins e eu caráter
hambúrguer é uma aula que eu gosto muito
de dar eu dou aula de culinária eu gosto
muito de dar essa aula porque o hamburgo
era um trunfo do skank criançada gosta
muito enfim uma aula que atrai nem na
hora de montar o cdos a gente fez o
ketchup a gente fez a gostar da gente
fez a maionese bom fizemos o hambúrguer
só não fiz o pão eo queijo o resto tudo
é feito lá eu falei assim gente vamos
botar a alface eo tomate missão do hamas
eu não gosto da menina nove anos falou
'não gosto foi não tudo bem não tem
problema mas coloca porque a gente vai
tirar foto tem que ficar bonito na foto
e sem tomate alface a foto vai ficar
feio tudo isso vai ficar sem cor colocou
na hora de comer prova fazer uma coisa
como essa folha uma folhinha só de
alface e nem vai sentir o gosto e se
tomate então acordei fininho a fatia da
bola como eu
cinco anos depois eu mantive contato é
com essa mãe filha e cinco anos depois
eu encontrei a mãe ela touch o tão feliz
lembra aquela aula de hamburgo você fez
uma folha de alface uma fatia fina de
tomate aquilo despertou na minha filha o
gosto ea vontade de comer salada hoje
lacombe pratos enormes não é uma opção
que ela cobre com gosto com prazer
ela incluiu várias outras coisas que ela
não comia na época
então assim eu fiquei super feliz com
isso fiquei super feliz de ter podido
colabora de uma forma simples e eu acho
que essa é a fórmula se é que existe
alguma fórmula para as crianças é seja
simples seja honesto
dica para o seu filho conversa
não não subestima a capacidade do teu
filho entendeu que ele deve ou não comer
o que ele pode ou não comer
na verdade tudo pode é o que eu sempre
digo para os meus filhos eu tenho um
diálogo super frango com eles tudo pode
tem coisa que pode e deve todo dia tem
coisa que só vai comer de vez em quando
e tem outras coisas que você vai evitar
o máximo mas você não vai deixar de
comer se você tiver vontade
é esse equilíbrio essa naturalidade com
a comida sem fazer disso uma neurose
eu acho que isso é muito saudável para
as crianças
exemplo não adianta você querer você
comer sanduíche porcaria salgadinho todo
o dia na frente do filho querer que ele
como o bichinho com salada isso não vai
acontecer
o exemplo que a gente dá para os filhos
vale infinitamente mais do que qualquer
recomendação falada e se eu vejo na
prática esse eu vejo quando as pessoas
começam a a cuidar da alimentação eu
acho que é super importante
criança não quebra a gente vai errar a
gente vai escorregar
a gente vai para umas porcariada de vez
em quando
isso não vai ter não vai facilitar em
nada a saúde do seu filho desde que a
rotina dele seja muito equilibrada e
seja muito saudável desde a gravidez viu
na barriga já tem que cuidar e é isso
obrigada
[Aplausos]